yo my is so [__] heterosexual he's
like we don't need women to survive I'm
like well you know life is better he's
like we don't need them we don't true
what's the point of even arguing for
that like what's the point of living if
there's no women there's no point I'm
saying we don't need them to survive is
the point but there's no point in living
so you're not going to want to survive
but you can survive without them why
would you survive if there were no women
why would you even do it there's other
ways to derive pleasure where you don't
need
females yeah women are a luxury bro
Sir Isaac Newton is another one there's
actually great men in history really mhm
there have been great men in history
that have died virgins um because they
believed that women were a distraction
and they were so focused on their
purpose